you didn't even want riffraff here right
was it here okay so like he helped kind
of yeah I mean I was I remember he was
living in Baltimore and I just was
watching videos and I had a label I saw
the label called Madison now just like
man this guy something special about him
and I linked him and had him come up to
LA and we worked a little bit and we
made his I signed him to his first album
on my label which for me in retrospect I
think was one of the most groundbreaking
hip-hop albums it's like new generation
and people don't believe me but every
time I work with a young rapper they
always brought him up like cuz they're
like 14 15 they watch him on YouTube and
he's like doing lines of coke or like
acting crazy or just being unabashedly
himself right yeah yeah everybody is
they had this free Lycia and they see
like this idea of like the freedom that
he did because he was like and he was
like the people on worldstar would
comment just he would blow up when Wall
Street was like [ __ ] this like you know
you're like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] but it's like drove the the
videos up to were like so confused and
if you're like an older person like I
don't get that hip-hop but if you're
like 14 15 like oh I love this love the
aspect of this so like that's a good
word he's like punk hip-hop yeah he was
Punk and he was just everything was
freestyle - I mean he was so same with
him I bet the podcast is just so good
cuz the guy's so fast like he just oh
he's a theory can everything see freakin
comes up with pulled out of space is
just like what the [ __ ] bro Iranian
Lamborghini dude he has uh what was the
alcohol I want to give him I know he has
a new album out right now going oh yeah
vanilla gorilla so everybody go and get
that and support riffraff man yeah I
love him dude when I'm so I went to his
place in the water field and yeah up in
Deerfield so we get there we go to the
front door right and I'm kind of nervous
because it's almost like meeting like an
endangered species yeah you don't know
for the first time you must be pretty
daunting and creature remember in
Jurassic Park when they kind of heard
milling around and they know that there
was out there I mean to see the big old
brontosaurus and it's kind of like that
yeah he's like that when you're riding
along you don't know where the animals
gonna kill ya and then we get to the
front door and it has been welded shut
there is no way actual door yes it's
just a huge piece of metal
why do you get in row that's fine so I
start just saying things that I'd seen
on Harry Potter you know like still
trying to open the try open the door and
then he takes us that he comes out his
assistant comes out through the garage
and he met us in there insistent he had
notice got Maserati mica oh yeah always
has people around there just like crazy
people I don't know
crazy but also slash Barber and Maserati
might give me some stripes in my head
too they were really really dope and I
felt like when he did that that I was
did he have the mullet when you
interview yeah he just got in it he has
a good mother
yeah oh he's got beautiful hair I cut
his brothers hair Victor is that he
don't know where it's a grand Instagram
mmm and he has good yeah he has a good
uh yeah that's a young mo now you're my
little fuller Punk you shaved the
insides a little bit more times
I mean riffraff I couldn't [ __ ] make
her flan with him without a bag cocaine
it was a [ __ ] wait a studio and there
was a painting I got like a gold record
on the wall he [ __ ] dug a hole behind
the painting at hid cocaine this I was
like where's the coke coming from my you
always had a bad cocaine hidden in a
wall socket somewhere and I was like it
without the cocaine he would be like
trying to write lyrics like what the
[ __ ] and then with a coke drop go in the
booth sixteen [ __ ] verses just
dropping I'm like left and right so not
to say you should do cocaine but for
some people it just helped a little bit
look it's Florida look that's considered
a hobby in Florida
and it's a little wet that's the thing
about that Florida coke came in its how
it got a little damp on the top it's
crazy the different places where drugs
are so accessible like Florida yeah Cook
was like people in high school were just
doing it I mean I when you know what's
the kids are doing nowadays
no either but I don't know if kids are
doing as much I wanted to I want to tell
the refresh story too because it is so
much fun there's something about him
it's like seeing the only it's like
somebody knows where there's like a
frickin like hippopotamus and they're
not telling anybody else you know he's
like he's just like and if you get its
he had a career long career nama he's
been like doing this like 10 years and
you going that YouTube down the hole
Donnell wouldn't go over there for like
a week yeah it's just crazy is if he cut
up a mango for me man he said he was
changing his diet mangos only told me
I've seen him go to a lot of different
diets man he was on a drug bending WWF
diet
oh yeah he's I think it's vegan though
he's a couple years and I mean he's in
sober so I think he's doing good for him
yeah last time I saw him he was getting
more and that was more the the vibe he
was going for
riff-raff has the best fries so I'll
pull I'll get there so I'll go into the
garage he shows me all the clothes that
I owned from 1991 right whose clothes
they're his but yeah actually they could
have been my child or the clothes he
just happen to have him in a box at his
house right he probably could still wear
him and makes sense about cuz bro he had
all just every anything that ever color
yeah anything anything with the Air
Jordan like more colors and like totally
all of that in the box then he's like
let's go for a ride so he give me this
pretty cool Bice was it a bicycle yes
like a motorized bike and he got on a
four-wheeler and we literally went
through his neighbor's I didn't say give
me a bison and I wrote it right we do
some coke with the body some went and
bought a couple grams while I was on it
that's a big bankroll that body yeah I
like I don't know if Joe Rogan but he
hits me surprising good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one